women no longer exist as characters in the movies
you cannot go to the movies and see a woman who is
anything like a woman that you would actually meet
unless you date wrestlers you know what I mean
you know and when my daughter was growing up there
would be a scene and a woman would punch a guy and
the guy would roll ass over teeth and I would say
to her you know if you punch a guy the first thing
that happens is your hand breaks and the second
thing that happens is he beats the living crap
out of you you know and so don't don't ever think
that that's the real thing so feminism destroyed
the character of the woman and yet that's what
stories are about they're about whether a woman
can be um womanly enough and whether a man can be
manly enough to keep life going is the West coming
to an end something is coming to an end and when
when things come to an end it's a very dangerous
moment and I think that there are probably a
hundred good years left to the republic or 100
years left to the public they may not be that good
and then and then I think something else will come
thank you hey Constantin do you like romantic
novels no in my countrymen who read romantic
novels are executed which is correct this is why
we don't have men with pink hair or women with
unshaved armpits oh I might chill out how about
if the character was woke even worse Lennon would
have been spinning his glass case but what if
it's satirical in my country would do not have
satar laughing is not allowed if you want humor
red dostoyevski well if you were blessed with
a sense of humor and enjoy a bitingly funny
takedown of romance novels and World culture
then you have to read Danielle's passion a new
set hour that follows a young ivy league grad as
she battles white supremacy the patriarchy and
late stage capitalism in the hellscape that is
Irvine California this is not natural live laugh
and love to the eyes of one of your most superiors
suffer every microaggression judge every co-worker
betray every family member as if you were doing it
yourself and come out feeling just as smug this
sounds like almost Russia now I'm interested in
this book it's comedy done the right way no
lectures no messages no characters banging on
about the same Tire talking points satire as it's
meant to be solved if you want great we'll go to
Amazon and click on link below we also recommend
you buy Tide moderates other books won't fragility
and a little book of woke jokes click on Luke
and laugh like you're reading Warren please
hello and welcome to trigonometry on the road from
the USA I'm Francis Foster I'm Constantine kitchen
and this is a show for you if you want honest
conversations with Fascinating People our terrific
yesterday is an author and former Hollywood
screenwriter Andrew cleven welcome to trigonometry
it's great to see you guys uh listen man it's
it's an absolute pleasure to have you on the show
there's so many things we're going to talk about
that I can't can't wait but for anyone who is not
familiar with your story it's a very interesting
one it's a it's a very interesting Journey you've
had in terms of your religion and Views and all
sorts of things so who are you how are you where
you are what's been your journey through life well
I'm right I've been a writer all my life it's all
I ever wanted to be I was a mystery writer I
kind of fell in love with the American tough
guy writers when I was a kid and so I made my way
as a mystery writer and did very well you know
won awards and had movies made and and then as
you say I kind of thought before I age out which
is I think about the age of 22 I wanted to try
Hollywood so I went to Hollywood and I did that
for a while and uh that was working well except
that I uh you were hugely successful done on the
players what's that you were hugely I was doing I
was doing quite well yeah in Hollywood I mean in
Hollywood you can do well without any movies
getting made you just sell the script you're
making a bundle and it was uh uh but I was having
fun but unfortunately I had been living in the UK
for uh seven years all through the 90s and I came
back and shortly after I came back 9 11 happened
and I had come back from the UK without realizing
it I had become politically conservative and I
didn't even know it because I wasn't dealing with
American politics I was dealing only with British
politics and you know I didn't really care I just
was paying attention to them and I came back and
I suddenly found that all of the people that I
liked listening to from Rush Limbaugh on uh were
conservatives and I thought well that's a shock
because I had left I had been a Jewish liberal
you know typical Jewish Coastal liberal um and
at the same time or really slightly afterwards
a long long journey of conversion Came Upon me
and so when I say I was Jewish I was racially
Jewish but I had no religion and I suddenly began
to realize I was a Christian and so at the same
time I became a loudmouth conservative because
9 11 had happened in Hollywood was making these
movies showing us as the bad guys and they were
making movie after movie showing us as the bad
guys and I thought this is a terrible thing to do
even the movies that were opposed to Vietnam were
made after Vietnam was over and so I started to
talk about that and write about that and I even
went to Afghanistan and had myself embedded with
the troops I could speak with authority and I said
you guys are really messing this this is wrong
it's wrong when when their guy it's not wrong to
disagree with the war but while our guys are being
shot at you shouldn't be making movies like this
well that on top of becoming a Christian my
Hollywood career died like that I mean it was
instantaneous but simultaneously because God does
take care of his poets and his fools uh and on
both I started to do these kind of satirical
videos about conservatism and that became a
second career and so now I I have this kind of
remarkable career it's like this is now uh as
I enter what must be the last phase of my life
unless I'm Immortal um you know I find myself
having the career of my of my dreams I'm writing
uh non-fiction about the things I understand in
the culture and how Christianity speaks through
them I'm still I have a new mystery Series going
on and I'm working at the daily wire as a
podcaster um and it's it's really been a
remarkable Journey the only thing I'm not doing
anymore is Hollywood and to be honest with you
I never really liked the movie business anyway I
mean it's just it was just something I did because
it seemed like the next step in my career right so
that's the one thing that has been I was literally
canceled I mean I was literally just blacklisted
and went dark there but other than that things
have been remarkable yeah uh and one of the things
you said to me because we met here last year
and I still remember this we were talking about
screenwriting and and writing in general and you
said every great Story begins with a boy and
a girl and once I got past the transphobia and
the homophobia of that statement it really made
me think because that is so fundamentally true
and yet I think we've become quite uncomfortable
with telling a story as basic as that or a story
that is based on such a simple thing well women
no longer exist as characters in the movies you
cannot go to the movies and see a woman who is
anything like a woman that you would actually
meet unless you date uh wrestlers you know what
I mean you know probably I mean if when you talk
about you know before the cameras are rolling
we're talking about all the controversial things
we say and how people get angry yeah maybe the
thing that made people angrier than anything
else I've ever said on the air was I I saw a show
The Witcher in which the woman was fighting a duel
and I said women can't fight duels with men that's
not the way that works I mean if it's the Middle
Ages and you're in an actual battle not on a
fencing field those guys were like you know it's
not like you'd be fighting me you'd be fighting
a guy this gigantic guy and he'd come and just
wipe you off the face of the Earth if you have a
character and a fantasy who's a woman she should
have some magical power because women do have that
but but you can't keep putting women in who fight
because that doesn't happen in real life and and
when my daughter was growing up there would be a
scene and a woman would punch a guy and the guy
would roll ass over teeth and I would say to her
you know if you punch a guy the first thing that
happens is your hand breaks and the second thing
that happens is he beats the living crap out
of you you know and so don't don't ever think
that that's the real thing so feminism destroyed
the character of the woman and yet that's what
stories are about they're about whether a woman
can be um womanly enough and whether a man can
be manly enough to keep life going to keep the
planet you know the human race uh continuing
um and and in telling that story you were telling
an essential uh what's called a psychomochy the
the inner battle that we all fight to bring
together the pieces of ourselves because we
all have female and male elements and we when you
put those together uh you are getting something
like the image of God you know in which we are
made and so that story is is the story and once
you lose that story you're not telling any story
at all and it really is interesting I mean I went
just the other day my wife and I went and saw the
new Dungeons and Dragons movie and the first thing
that happens is a giant bad guy comes in tip is
a classic scene because this is the scene where
Brad Pitt is reading the script and says oh yeah
I want to play that part bad guy comes in he's a
monster he's huge comes up to a woman the woman
just beats the crap out of him and I thought yeah
you've already lost me you know the rest and and
in fact the film is entertaining it's beautiful
but it's dead inside it has no inside because
that character that female character women no
longer know who they're supposed to be and they
get insulted if you say to them well you may be
many things but the one thing you're not is
a man you know and so you have to understand
what you are as a woman and that that has been
outlawed as a as an idea and signify something
in the culture to me that that very basic it's
the core it's like a house without a foundation
well you know I I wrote this book The the truth
and beauty and I have a chapter on Frankenstein
by Mary shellin and I point out that when people
read Frankenstein it's it really starts the
science fiction genre she basically invents the
modern uh science fiction when people read that
they always say well Frankenstein wanted to be God
he wanted to create life and Mary Shelley herself
said this and I thought no men do create life men
and women do create life he wants to replace not
God he wants to replace the mother he wants to
create a life without a woman and and that is to
a large degree with science fiction is about and
to a large and even larger and worst degree with
science is about it has been a long uh attempt
to eliminate the fertility and the difference
of women because men are afraid of that power and
that's what Mary Shelley I thought first saw that
you know if you think of think of a movie like
The Terminator you know the machines take over and
they and the people rebel so how do they stop the
Rebellion they go back in time to kill the hero's
mother and if you see watch that first brilliant
film the woman they want to kill she has nothing
special about her except she she's a girl that's
her superpower you know and they know they've
got to kill her because that's the Machine World
depends on women being taken away this is you know
just right this moment people were yelling at me
on Twitter because I said we should uh boycott
Anheuser-Busch for putting a boy pretending to be
a girl on one of their beer cans they said oh this
is such a small thing why are you getting so upset
this is everything this is everything the role of
women in a society who after all create humankind
um is is everything and that's why societies that
have Freer women who liberate women who have
respect for women that's why they Thrive and
societies that don't get stuck
in a kind of medieval half-life
and it's important because soon there'll be
machines that give birth and then we'll turn
to women and say and what do you what's special
about you I can run faster than you I'm stronger
than you are I can do math better than you can
do it what is it you do again and they'll have
lost their vocation it's a dangerous dangerous
moment and because our Humanity depends on them
it's such a profound point and that's that is
really what we're seeing and we're seeing it right
the way through our culture when are we going to
wake up from this Andrew well hopefully you know
we're not going to wake up until women get angry
and and this is the thing you know uh my friend
and colleague at the daily wire Candace Owens was
just saying when they did it to Budweiser beer
suddenly Budweiser beer took an economic hit and
she said why because Men drink Budweiser beer and
they get angry but women not real men not right no
of course of course not and certainly not men with
any taste and beer or anything but but she was
just saying that men don't take this stuff quite
as much as women do women have been convinced my
problem with feminism was always the same thing
it was always it was not that women shouldn't
have choices it was that their values are men's
values they say oh you're just a homemaker I think
really just a homemaker I mean is I mean isn't the
home the basic building block of the State uh you
know just you're just raising children you're just
creating new people that has been the feminist
uh archetype from the very beginning uh Simone
de beauvois said women should not be allowed to
stay home and raise their kids because too many
women will choose to do that and they have been
convincing women uh that this is a minor thing
this is being thrown out of the society So when
you say how long will this last the answer is
until you start to have women saying wait a
minute wait a minute we've been duped we've
been duped out of ourselves and you're starting
to see it now I mean we were talking about Mary
Harrington who's just This brilliant uh you know
Oxford educated thinker and she you know had a
baby she was totally in with the left had a baby
and she thought no I actually kind of like this
I actually kind of want to do this and when
more thinking women have that kind of Courage
then you've got you'll have ideas trickling
down that will counter feminism because
feminism has just been a mistake it has
made everybody miserable you wonder why yeah
but let's move to the movie business for a
little bit I'm a huge movie fan okay I've
Loved movies right the way from from Year Dot it's
my passion my love movie buff movie nerd whatever
what's going on with the movies I can't remember
I mean there's the odd movie that comes along I go
oh I'd like to see that but nothing really compels
me like it used to yeah but what's going on well
there's there's two things one is that art forms
have a natural life cycle uh you know they can
come back they don't necessarily die forever but
they rise up at their Peak usually very early on
to me the peak year of the movies is 1939 I mean
and what happens at that Peak is that the popular
movies and the critically acclaimed movies are
the same movie so when you get it when you get
oh I see where this is going well it's true you
know you've got an era like where the theater is
thriving Shakespeare is the popular playwright uh
you're getting the novels are thriving Dickens you
know one of the greatest novel novelists ever
is also the best-selling novelist 1939 if you
look at the 10 Oscar nominees they're also some of
the greatest films ever made including the Wizard
of Oz and you know I don't know if gone with the
win was that year but it's almost that year um Mr
Smith one of the Frank Capital as an art form ages
out they split into uh popular trash like these
Marvel movies these superhero movies and these
kind of tiny little intellectual exercises that
the critics think are oh so important but the rest
of us can't stay awake through and that that's the
one thing that's happening it's simply a matter
of the art form aging out and a lot of that energy
went over to TV in the 2000s the early 2000s I
remember watching a show here called the shield
and thinking oh gee they're doing everything
I did in the golden the second golden age of
mystery writing I was writing characters just
like this and now they've all moved over to TV
and that and we had 20 years of great TV here I
mean it was really brilliant stuff but the other
thing is this this idea of of wokeness which is
actually uh a very deep we use it as a slogan
uh as a catch word but it's actually a very
deep philosophical moment it is the bottom of
atheistic philosophy and it's impossible to make
a good story out of it because it has no inner
life it the whole the whole premise of wokeness
is there is no spiritual life there's only Power
everything that we believe in is power femininity
is power masculinity the constructs of power and
so they can't say anything you can't you can't
say anything about what it is to be a human being
you know uh there is we're talking about there
are no women characters I've always thought what
would it what would happen if you told a story in
which a woman character starts out as a powerful
business woman and then says you know what I
don't want to do this I want to make a family
I want to I want a man to take care of me so I can
do this you know you can't make that movie and yet
that is the movie right you can't make a movie
where a guy comes to town and builds a business
and he's the hero of the movie you know because
it's all about power so if he has power he must
be the bad guy when you get rid of the spiritual
life there's only Power and and that's not a good
story wow you know what you're investment of uh
to I don't know if you're familiar with him he's
a KGB Defector uh from the Soviet Union uh in in
the like he has lectures on YouTube and this is
uh this is one of the things he talked about how
in the movies at certain point uh the police the
generals the army they all became the bad guys
the criminal is the good one the the KGB uh not
not the KGB the army colonel he's always the
dumb one the the whatever but I want to come
back to the first of those two Andrew because
what you're talking about is a perfect metaphor
for politics more broadly because you you have a
an elite that is so up its own us it is completely
out of touch with ordinary person and so which
is typical by the way right we're right and so
that's why the movie or that that there's the
screen the screenshots from like the Rotten
Tomatoes ratings for comedy shows like a Dave
Chappelle latest show or a movie and now their
their parodies on themselves where like critics a
hundred percent you know uh for the for they like
or dislike something and it's the opposite way
for the ordinary person right and it seems to me
like it's not just about aging out it's about a
fundamental Detachment of the people in in a in
like in this case in Hollywood from the people who
they're supposed to provide services or content
or whatever it is right but this is how this is
how an art form dies it is it is a coagulation of
power in a way you know we're sitting a few
miles from Washington in Washington you can
go to Georgetown named after Washington and walk
down the street that used to be called Washington
Street with inside of the Washington Monument in
the middle of Washington DC so you get the picture
that George Washington a lot of a big effect on
this um on this country and the thing that is
Washington's signal moment is having defeated
the British in this defeated the greatest Empire
on Earth with his ragtag band of you know half
starlings uh that's wandering around in the snow
he's got he's the king of a continent he can
be the king of a continent there was nothing
to stop him and he takes he goes to uh somewhere
in Maryland and Annapolis and he turns over his
sword to the civilian Powers because he believed
that much in the idea of The Sovereign people
that also just like you said has aged out
so that at that moment the most popular man
in America was also the best man in America and
probably one of the best men who ever lived you
know he was like but he was also the most now
like the people who are popular are completely
detached from the the power and the people who are
powerful are completely detached from the people
um the Advent of Donald Trump which even at the
time I said you know this is a tragic moment when
it takes a man like Donald Trump to speak for
the people because everybody and you saw the
way the power Just Came to shut him down this
is not about whether Trump's a nice person or
a good person or anything like that it's simply
what he represented to people for for 50 years
50 years the powers that be told people in
this country you stink your country stinks
your religion stinks your cut the color of your
skin stinks everything about your history it
stinks you know like your God doesn't exist and
then they thought well why did they elect Donald
Trump you know my feeling was you're lucky
they didn't show up outside your house with
a torch and a pick Pitchfork and toss you into
the Potomac you know this was the nice thing
electing Donald Trump was the nice thing to do
so you're absolutely right I mean I think that
um as as people people think their way out
of morality as as they think their way out of
your individuality the importance of your
individuality it's easy for me to feel my
individuality and my reality but you have to have
to sort of really think about it to think oh you
know maybe that guy's sitting across from me is
just as important to himself as I am to me and and
that we're both equally important to God then you
have art then you have the enlightenment then you
know once you get that idea then you have all the
kind of beautiful things that that Europe produced
and once you lose that idea you lose everything
and and I think you're absolutely right that kind
of coagulation of of power money uh political
ideas in in an aristocracy that does not care
anymore for the people that has no no blessed
oblige is the way a country ages out as well
hey KK do you like trigonometry of course I
do incredible interviews fascinating guests
phenomenal live shows and hilarious raw streams in
that case you need to join our locals so you can
have access to even more brilliant content that's
right you get the chance to win incredible prizes
ask our phenomenal guests your questions access
extra content and now the only place to watch our
Roars on catch up is on locals are War shows still
go out at 7 pm UK time 2 p.m Eastern as normal but
if you want to watch them after this time then
you're gonna need to sign up to our locals Ross
have now become too spicy to stay on YouTube so
they're only available to watch back on our locals
page all you need to do to sign up is click on the
link below this video and for just seven dollars
a month you have access to All of This brilliant
content seven dollars a month even for someone of
my persuasion that's a bargain see fuel on locals
and you can see it but going back to this idea of
the movies where the values that America used to
embody and use to celebrate if you think about
the movies of the 80s and 90s strength resilience
Independence taking responsibility for yourself
you look at the movies now and they just
it's unrecognizable you think to yourself
what message are you trying to send me how are
you trying to inspire me yes well that's well
that is a you know it's an amazing thing the
people who built the movie industry the people
who made the movies I I love and probably you
love as well many of them were immigrants many
of them were Jews and they loved this place
they loved America I mean because they'd seen
what the rest of the world was like especially
the Jewish guys they knew exactly what what they
had going on in America and they were liberal
in the sense that they wanted to be included
but they were businessmen who thought their
business depended on the audience liking what
they did so if the audience was Christian they
give them Christians they have a scene where
the Christian guy would be nice to a Jew and
then and you know that would give you a good
feeling and they would say yes we're part of
this country too and everybody said yes you are
that that was great stuff but they loved they
may not have loved the people uh individually
but they loved them as the audience they were
their source of their income they were the source
of their popularity their power everything
and they served them they served the people
partially because the studio system was destroyed
by the courts the essentially the inmates took
over the Asylum uh in Hollywood this is part
of the the deaths throws of the industry but
you had this moment when they lost the studio
system Studios had a monopoly they had a monopoly
on theaters the court said you can't they it
was a trust busting case and they destroyed that
so ultimately now the power rested with actors
and not with businessmen and so you got you have
actors who were great businessmen like Arnold
Schwarzenegger and Tom Cruise they're great
businessmen but they're still not about the
people those are bad examples because Cruz and
Schwarzenegger actually are about the people but
so many of these guys you know you make a movie
even an Oscar to a movie like what was it called
Moonlight was that was what it was called it was
when oscar-winning film about a black gay guy
discovering that he's gay you know it wasn't a bad
film but it was like a slice of Life about this
you know like this and then you think about Gone
With the Wind you think about the movies that have
won Oscars that were just gave you all of life
you know they gave you so many Casablanca I mean
that that movie you can watch that movie today you
can watch it twice in a row today and it'll still
break your heart whereas you know a black gay guy
in the in the ghettos is an interesting story I'll
watch that once you know it's not it's not telling
me something that I need to know to get forward
in life whereas the fact that sometimes you have
to give up the thing you love for a greater cause
is something I needed to know the movies shaped
you know it's funny the Arts shaped me you know
I I wasn't happy at home I had a bad relationship
with my dad I went to the first to novels and then
to movies for male role models and I found Bogart
John Wayne these you know Raymond Chandler's
Philip Marlow the great detective guy Sam Spade
um and they taught me these simple things you
know they taught me how to walk they taught me
you know how to what you what you would sacrifice
for they taught me that you would sacrifice for
something during the pandemic recently there was
this moment when Donald Trump got covered and he
came back to the White House and he said I've
now I've had covet Don't Be Afraid don't let
it dominate your life and there is this Montage
that I play on my show from time to time of the
news media coming out going what a horrible
thing to do of course you should be afraid of
course this this could kill you what's wrong you
know that and I I don't know if I was the last
person in America with all those movies in my head
saying wait a minute you know there are there are
things that are more important than dying you know
like slavery like being like losing your freedom
like losing your dignity like you know losing the
chance to be the thing that you want to be people
have died for all those things through time and
yet here with the news that was the news media
one of them after another say no no no that mean
awful Donald Trump you know you must be afraid
you must be afraid and then they sit around
going why would anybody vote for Donald Trump
you know these are the things we learned from the
movies uh and we learned them before that from you
know British novels I think more than anything
else uh and these are the things that are gone
in my opinion from a world without God because why
would you why would you risk your life if there's
nothing Beyond yourself you know why would you
risk your life for anything if there's nothing
Beyond yourself if something doesn't have a
quality of the Eternal to it uh like Freedom like
uh you know justice of those things why would you
die for them if uh if everything is just material
you know you're here you're gone and that's
the reason I'm such a huge Arthur Miller fan
the playwright Arthur Miller and his wife for me
the the play The Crucible resonates harder than
ever especially now yeah when you have Proctor
and he give John Procter at the end when he's
about to he's about to die and he refuses to give
give up anybody else and he says but leave me my
name that's all I have that's all that any man
has yes and and then think you know with Andrew
Cuomo who's made a hero he was the governor of
New York yeah and he was made into a hero the
anti-trump yeah and he said you know we have to
do all this stuff because it's death and nothing
is worse than death death is death and death
when you're dead you're dead you know you just
look like who are these people like like run and
hide everybody and and you know this is this is
kind of the instrument of power everything is
a catastrophe everything is an emergency the
climate is an emergency you go like you know it's
it's a little warm today oh my it's an emergency
give me more power you know racism is an emergency
reason this is a health emergency you know give
us more power uh the covert is emergency give us
more power there's always back to that you know
it's always basically they're gonna take care of
it let me ask you a question I don't like asking
because I don't like hearing the answer but if
Hollywood is aged out and comedy is aged out and
and if we're seeing the same thing in in Western
political systems is the West coming to an end
well it's a good question uh the West has come to
an end before uh and it came it came slowly back
um my guess is I don't think so something is
coming to an end and when when things come
to an end it's a very dangerous moment
um the baby boom generation is dying
um there's no generation to take their place I did
a Show recently about King Lear which is about the
same situation the old man is dying there's
nobody to take his place because they haven't
learned the things you need to learn to take uh
to take the next gener the last Generations plays
uh the post-world War II order is done a post
uh Cold War order is dying a lot of stuff is
coming to an end right now and in times like that
certain things happen there's gender confusion
always always gender confusion in moments like
this uh there's a the threat of War because
there's no common ground right now in America we
have no common ground there's no Common Ground
between left and right plenty of Common Ground
among the people like I would say about 70 percent
of the people probably agree on seventy percent
of the ideas but among the loudest people uh
there's no common ground and that's a that's could
could lead to actual shooting War um however I
think that the foundation on which America stands
and the alliance that it has built with both what
was once great Europe and some of you know Israel
and the Middle East and Eastern Europe I I think
there's a lot of energy still in there political
energy and Military energy and possibly Financial
energy and what I if I had to predict something
uh what I would say I'm much more afraid of losing
the American Republic than I am of losing America
so remember after the Roman Republic fell Roman
Empire Still lasts another 400 years it lasted as
long as it had already lasted so I'm I'm fearful
for our Republic because it's not working it has
ceased to work the way it's supposed to operate
um but I still feel you know China I don't think
so people keep telling me Oh China's the future
I don't think so I think it's a stagnant it's
all an already dying Society I don't think you
can have a free market without political freedom
I think they've made a mistake I think they're
going to age out too you know I I think that I
think that the West still has something in it
and that what we're really seeing now I mean one
of the things that happened in Rome like if you
were in Rome you were thinking where are all the
Romans all these immigrants are coming in this is
bad Romans but actually that's that's the sign
of an idea spreading all these people who are
shouting at us that they're not being treated
fairly are shouting British ideas of us you
no it's like you don't go you don't go to like
Africa and say you know we want to be equal
because that doesn't mean anything in Africa
you know it only means something here because
we're all British that's that's why so what's
happening really is we're bringing in the people
of the world we're anglicizing them that's our job
I think I think that's just the same way the Roman
job was to spread the ideals of Greece I think the
American job is to spread the ideals of England I
think that's actually happening and I think that
there are probably a hundred good years left to
the republic or 100 years left to the public
they may not be that good and then and then
I think something else will come you know but I
think it will still be Western uh for a long time
that's my guess I say that and we could all
blow up as we're speaking here but that's my
that's my guess you know I I see when I talk
when I talk to Andrew I I enjoy it so much
because when I went into the art I expected it
to be full of people like you people questioning
people opening who are open we could debate we
could discuss you disagree you see yourself as
a conservative I remember you when we were having
a conversation you looking at me and going you're
a conservative you just don't know it yet which
is what I get from everybody when I come here but
the Arts isn't full of people like you it isn't
full of people who are interesting and interested
and curious and open to new ideas why is that
what's gone wrong you know it's a really good
observation when I when I was coming up I was you
know I fell in with some really talented writers
some of them went on to have really great
careers and the discussions that we would
have were fantastic you know talking about what is
happening to storytelling where we want us to take
storytelling what storytelling meant to us within
years we had all done fairly well and we were
talking about who's your agent how'd you get that
why did you get that deal I didn't get that deal
nobody said you know and I thought I hate these
people I'm not talking to people and and one of
the things that was kind of lovely about becoming
a writing thinking conservative was suddenly I saw
that again when we were building the daily wire
the daily wire started it was me and Ben Shapiro
and Jeremy boring and soon Michael Knowles came
in and we did nothing but fight with each other
we we fought so much that sometimes the women I
I remember once I went home and one of the women
called me and said are you in Ben okay and I said
yeah that's how we talked to one another because
we were screaming it you know but it was totally
friendly it was just we were just absolutely and
and something about success takes that out of
people you know they they want to hold on to what
they've got and they lose that I've never lost it
I mean this is why I'm here I'm here to talk and
debate and hear things I'm here to be proved
wrong you know I mean I I being proved wrong
doesn't mean anything to me because it means I've
now learned something new you know I've actually
broken through a wall a cage that I was in but
this is it's it's a remarkable thing because
one of the drawbacks to this internet culture
is that if you're wrong people are like you
were wrong you know it was yeah you know that
happens to me sometimes it may happen again
uh but but to me that's that is that's the
glory of of doing what we do uh that you can
that you can grow and you can change and that
the books that you write uh at 50 or not the
books we write at 30 in the books that you
write a 70 shouldn't be the books you write
at 52 you know you should get deeper and richer
and that means leaving things behind but you're
absolutely right we are in a culture that has
shut that first we were in a culture I just
saw it as as people got rich they started stopped
doing it that may just be part of nature you know
um but also we're in a culture that doesn't allow
you to do that like you know there's a there's a
problem in this country where I think 50 of the
murders in this country are committed by black
people now to me that's a really big question why
is that now I have a theory about it my theory is
it has to do with the programs that the left
instituted uh during the 60s 70s and 80s that
made them a dependent class turned blacks into a
dependent class but Charles Murray is a terrific
thinker and he believes it's genetics and of
course then the left has their theory that it's
all racism and they're you know it's we we did
this to them um you can't have that conversation
you know for saying what I even for saying what I
just said I'm a racist oh I flinched even though I
know the statistics and I've listened to Larry
Elder and Thomas I'll talk about it and I've
looked at the arguments I Flinch when you say
it yeah because that's the culture we're in I
I brought up Charles Murray at the dinner party in
LA and somebody said isn't he that racist you know
he's he's not a racist at all but he does believe
in genetic more than I do I'm not like a big and
he could be wrong he could be totally wrong you
know but I I had him on the show I wanted to hear
what he had to say and he made a you know we had
a really interesting conversation and I I pushed
back against him he was absolutely civilized and
you know pushed back against me it was it was
great stuff uh but we have now shut that down and
that too is contributing to the uh atrophy of the
Arts because what are the Arts but you know that
kind of open-mindedness I mean they you can't even
write a story you can't even write a story if you
don't have an open mind because your story has to
mean things that you didn't mean it to me for a
story to come to life you have to let it set it
free you know you can't just say oh this this has
to happen to that character because I'm a you know
I'm a capitalist and I don't want the Communist to
win you can't write a story like that you have to
let the story tell itself you know um and all
of that stuff requires a certain fearlessness
that artists are renowned for but have no longer
got um you know you can I mean I have I'm writing
this new series of uh mystery stories uh and and
I have a new one the third one is coming out in
October at the end of October and I handed it in
and had a glancing reference to transgenderism
maybe five lines so you have to take this out
I said I will pull that book before I take out
anything for political reasons you know you know
one of my the New York Times is going to give me
a bad review I've said things about the New York
Times I think they may show up in my house one
day like no you know that that's insane it's
insane to have to kowtow to you know a bunch of
and basically adolescents who've been taught
something in college and don't know enough to
disagree you know I mean that's it's it's very
stultifying and it's also as you say it's it's
dull you know I want to be with people who
who disagree and are fearlessly disagree and
um and don't call each other names you know
when when they say something and Andrew
forgive me for saying this but what you're
describing to me are old school liberal values
yes so this is what I find mind-boggling
I'm 40 years old when I was a young guy
watching comedy and being inspired by it the
people who were really pushing back against
the dogma of the day were people like George
Carlin and Bill Hicks who whose targets were
religious conservatives right so if you talk about
stultifying they were the ones you know Bill Hicks
last Letterman appearance was wasn't broadcast
for I think over a decade because he made fun
of religion right so when I came into adulthood
it was conservatives at least that was the kind
of the way it was presented who were the people
who were refusing to have the conversation right
and it was the liberals who were let's let's
have that robust debate that you're talking
about that was the lifeblood of my my young
adulthood that was what I loved I cherished that
so what happened how like you you talked about it
in your own life you were this you know liberal
went over to the UK came back conservative uh and
we on neither of us is conservative but we find
ourselves mostly talking to people who are in the
center or right of center right because the left
does the six degrees of white supremacy thing
where if you talk to this guy and he sat next
to that guy who's dog blah blah blah then you
can't you know you can't talk to them anymore
how how how are the three of us sitting here well
because when I said to you that you know Francis
that you're a conservative I I said this to Mary
Harrington who also tells me she's on the left but
but there is no left there is no you know in the
in the 50s I think it was a famous literary critic
named Lionel trilling said there is no until such
thing as an intellectual conservative there are
no conservative ideas they're only conservative
gestures you know it was a very snobby snooty
thing to say but he had a point now that's true of
the left but it's not true of the right uh on the
left there there are no ideas there are no ideas
on the left I mean you know their their ideas are
like yeah you can print money because that's fine
and you know you can't arrest black people because
they're brown they have this color skin and you
know you're you're white and therefore you're evil
you know those aren't ideas those are gestures
those are kind of virtue signaling uh movements
of the of the chin but they're not like something
that you can debate in any serious way a man can
become a woman you know as if yeah like what are
you even talking about on the right basically the
right now contains those people like me I mean I
always say this I always say I'm a conservative
because I'm a liberal I'm a conservative because
I want people to be free I want other people to be
able to have the life that they want to have
not the life I want them to have I know how
everybody should live you know I could explain to
you but but it's none of my business you know you
know that that actually is my religion that's
actually in the gospels you know leave people
alone don't judge people you know let them
do what they're going to do let them work
out their salvation with fear and trembling that
attitude is now a right-wing attitude so if you
have that attitude you are somewhere on the right
um how did that happen well I think it happened
because ideas first of all follow themselves
follow themselves out to their furthest extreme
and the idea that the government uh should
is is the solution to problems has followed
itself out to its its furthest extreme but also
power corrupts and the left has so much power
um you know this is what killed me during the
Trump administrations they call themselves The
Resistance so I thought so you've got you've
got the Deep State you know the Deep Cover
the permanent government you've got the uh media
you've got the entertainment and the news media
the academies you've got now the corporations
you've got big Tech what are you resisting against
I thought oh yeah you're resisting the people
you're existing the ordinary guy so you know the
idea of the left has played itself out as I keep
telling my friends on the right if we come back
and win the power we'll become corrupt because
power corrupts I mean that was the whole point
of the country the whole point of this country was
to create a sort of uh Rube Goldberg machine that
every time somebody came too powerful somebody
else knocked them down you know oh you know you've
got the states we've got the federal government
you've got the courts we you know we've got the uh
the states whatever it was there was always some
Power Center to take it away but beginning with
the turn of the century beginning really with
Woodrow Wilson this the federal government be
started to become so powerful uh and and the Le
that is the left-wing's dream to have a federal
government that can tell everybody what to do so
they've got they want they won and when you win
you lose you know when you when you win you your
ideas stagnate you know there's no one there's no
one they can't Crush there's no one they can't
destroy there's no idea they can't demonize
um you know there's one now that's not quite true
but for the last say 30 years there's been one
conservative news station Fox News and all you
heard was all fall Fox and oh my God you know
you would say to people like I heard yesterday
on Fox News oh Fox no no don't tell me about
Fox News you think like one one new station and
that's the problem with the country is that one
group of people you know now it's it's Tucker
Carlson you know Tucker Carlson you know has I
don't always agree with Tucker Carlson but he's
like he's like you mentioned his name and it's
like you mentioned Satan they're so powerful they
can demonize anybody they can silence anybody they
can cancel anybody so why should they discuss
things why should they discuss anything with
anybody and so that to me is death it's all about
power it's all about power you know and and and
we have forgotten if you go back and read The
Federalist Papers where they're arguing for the
Constitution against the people who didn't
want um who thought the federal government
was going to get too strong they only turned
out to be right several hundred years later
um they all they talk about is power all those
people you know this is Madison and uh you know
all these guys and all they talk about is how
do we keep people from getting too much power
um and and we have forgotten that
that's even a a problem so when you say
when you say for instance um you know we've
got all these shootings in this country these
mass shootings we should get rid of people's guns
nobody even on the right people don't think to say
well isn't that giving the federal government a
monopoly on violence and it's not giving them too
much power you know the answer is always no guns
save lives guns you know protect us we need guns
for home protection that's not why they gave us
guns they give us guns so the states would have
the power to form militias to fight the army of
the federal government that is why they gave us
guns I tried to explain this to a conservative
British broadcaster and he looked at me like I
was a Savage you know and I said I get it you know
I don't want people getting shot but that's why we
have guns are we not going to at least debate the
real reason why Americans are supposed to carry
guns when when you say oh here's a poor person
I'm going to start a federal program to save that
person my question is isn't that a Temptation
you know aren't we giving you money so that now
you can buy that guy's vote essentially you know
I don't want people to be poor I want you know I
want charity to flow in this country when people
are rich I want the charity to flow to those who
are disadvantaged but don't we even debate how
power collects how power follows money are we not
even going to talk about that it's all about power
when it comes to politics that's what politics is
and we don't even talk about it anymore the idea
that you know obviously if if a right-winger
starts to do something the Press will gang I was
always a fascist you know he disagreed with me
as a fashion but if the left does something no
matter how much power a great example recently
they indicted Donald Trump on an absolutely
nonsense charge absolute nonsense complete abuse
of power by the uh New York D.A all we heard from
the left was ever no one's Above the Law no one's
Above the Law I kept saying what law was even died
I don't know but all right no one's above the law
then the Supreme Court made a decision
that Alexandria ocasio-cortez our left-wing
Firebrand uh you know congresswoman didn't
like so well we should ignore the courts
but they have so much power that no one's Above
the Law if you're a conservative oh you started
during covert you mentioned it earlier right
we saw in the UK everyone must stay at home
for the safety of everyone BLM happens everyone
must go out into the streets because protesting
is a health intervention right right but yeah
but if you protest the lockdowns then you're
right-wing scum and you should have your face
that's the thing that's power and when you have
that kind of power you don't argue with that
why would you argue and you can just silence
people in a recipe you know and then and then your
ideas die and you have no ideas and that's that's
basically where the left is now I mean they are a
rotten branch and that's why I mean everything is
what's the word uh everything's circumstantial
so we have circumstances here that
that may make it difficult to win power back from
them but as a but they're just a rotten branch and
eventually they're going to just break off because
they have nothing to say except give me more you
know give me more power it's an emergency give me
power you know you know the more I I spend time in
this country and I love America so much I really
do and I I hope that I one day come to live here
it seems to me that America the thing
that set it apart from every other country
is that it was forged with Rebel spirit and
I look at it now and there doesn't seem to be
a lot of that Spirit left is that part of the
problem yeah the you know even the right even
the right has has fallen a foul of has tripped
over its own ideas you know when when the right
Ronald Reagan gave us 25 good years and that what
he did got translated into business is everything
the market is everything that's not what Reagan
believed but that's what the reaganites believe
and so we had this Market Market that would talk
about Ein Rand who to my mind is just a sociopath
you know like not not to mention a terrible
terrible writer um but that that's kind of
empty too you know like this this whole notion
that some system is going to take care of us uh
it just doesn't work I I think we definitely need
there's a lot of things we need and I hesitate to
say to Englishmen that one of them is uh is
a rebirth of religion but uh it's true I mean
if we don't if we don't at least start talking
as if we live we're Spirits instead of animals
um I think that we're we're finished you know
we're finished we can't make the arguments we
need to make in a materialist way um you know
I forgot what was your original question it
was about the rebel Spirit or the rebel Spirit yes
well that that is also this question well it is it
does go back to materialism because if you're
afraid to die everything comes down to I must
save my life at all costs how can you be a rebel
why would you be a rebel against how how powerful
would you be how powerful how much would you go
against the power to say what you have to say
New York I I lived in New York during one of the
worst times in the 70s 1970s it was you could
hardly go out without you know dodging bullets
I mean it was really something I used to go to
work at three in the morning uh and I would
run from my apartment to stand in front of a
um a marketplace where there were prostitutes
because I figured if there were prostitutes the
mob wouldn't let there be violence and I was the
only guy who in my Newsroom who didn't get mugged
because that's what I would do every morning
it was terrible but it was tough I mean the New
Yorkers were tough and they were they really would
not kowtow to anybody when covid came you know my
daughter still lives in New York I'd go and visit
and everybody was like oh you're not wearing
a mask you know don't come near me they were
terrified they were terrified so something you
know maybe it's maybe it's wealth maybe it's too
much wealth maybe it's too much safety uh you know
this is a wealthy safe country in a lot of ways
but also this kind of idea that death is the end
you know this this this this flesh is all you've
got you've got to take care of it you know because
now we can be so healthy for so long we mustn't
sacrifice all those wonderful years that we've got
you know I don't want to die nobody wants to die
but like that you must believe in something bigger
than yourself we have become cowardly haven't
because you know people talk about cancer culture
and you know people shouldn't be canceled I agree
but you know people say to us oh you're so brave
you know you stood up to the comedy industry and
started what are you talking about what's Brave
about it I said this you know when I got thrown
out of Hollywood we had to sell our house we were
living in one of the nicest areas in the country
we had to sell our house because my my income went
from sometimes seven figures to nothing
like that I mean just gone you know
I never lost a moment's sleepover I mean I
wasn't happy about it but I kept saying to
people you know people are in Afghanistan they're
having their legs blown off like 18 year old kids
are being blown to Kingdom Come fighting for
something that they think has to be fought for
I can't work in Hollywood you know oh really am
I that scared you know and and like believe me
as you say we're not Heroes I mean those guys
were Heroes you know we're not we're but but
We're Men I mean we have to we have to stand
for something you have to be somebody you know
um and and so yeah that that has gone
terribly terribly wrong this idea that some
you know it's funny that like my career has gone
well and I've been really thrilled but it wasn't
until I got to the Daily wire that I became
a celebrity that I became somebody that gets
recognized and I remember and so I was old you
know I was like and I remember walking into a
hotel and being mobbed like a rock star because
I was talking politics on the internet you know
just like I pressed to the wall by like a hundred
kids like and I thought well if this had happened
to me when I was 20 I would be like genuinely
lost I mean I would have genuinely become a fool
you know but now I think like you know it comes
and goes you know I get it but this has become so
important to people that once they get their hands
on it they don't want to let go of and they become
afraid yeah the idea oh my God I might be canceled
and you see it it's so pitiful it breaks my heart
to see people come out and say you know something
so obvious like a man can't become a woman you
know is that somebody I can't remember who it was
just said JK Rowling is Right within minutes she
apologized oh I'm so sorry you know that kind of
Soviet uh show trial thing like I'm so sorry I'm a
sinner I'm you know please yeah yeah you know when
someone is really messed up because they take a
screenshot of an apology and then pin it to their
Twitter yeah you have to zoom in that's the moment
you know oh somebody's friends they're really
[__] up yeah they have really messed this one up
I I have reached a point where like I don't even
apologize for things that I should apologize for
you know like I mean there are things you really
should apologize for but at this point it's just
blood in the water to these people you know I
mean yeah now you have to apologize when you've
done something wrong of course we have to model
that I think yeah more than anything don't you
think part of the problem with the Arts is to
me the artist the true artists are the rebels
and there's no Rebellion anymore if you
if you think about the great writers
they were the rebels The Comedians were the
Rebels the actors who did we fall in love with
the Jimmy Deans the Jack Nicholsons and Marlon
brandos they just want people accepted by Society
no that's true that's true and they represented
that that Force certainly since since the Romantic
Era that was the idea of the artist the artist was
a special thing he was he was you know it almost
was a replacement of the priest but you know
Rebellion yes but I don't think it's necessarily
bit that Rebellion is the key thing I think it's
freedom freedom because even even a conservative
an artist who is writing for the conservative
cause a trollop say you know somebody who's
actually more uh who who likes the established
things than the traditional things he's got to be
free to say that in the exactly the way he means
to say it and so I don't require of an artist
that he Rebel because first of all Rebellion now
has become just virtue signaling I mean people
rebel like I said they call themselves uh the
uh resistance but they're really the power uh I
don't think Rebellion is the thing I'm looking for
I'm Looking For Freedom um you know we're talking
about JK Rowling when I read some I I have I'm not
a child so I didn't read all of the Harry Potter
books but I read a couple of them just to sample
them because my kids were so into them I thought
yeah there's a there's a someone who is free with
her creativity she is being generous she's just
saying I'm not saving this for the next page I'm
throwing it on this page I'm getting you know that
kind of Liberty that you see in genuine artists
and I think it's liberty more than Rebellion
I think I think it becomes Rebellion because the
minute power sees Liberty it seeks to crush it so
it becomes Rebellion you know so you have to stand
where you're going to stand but but you know I
I think of Shakespeare sometimes and sometimes the
the great movies that were made during the Hayes
office years and they didn't necessarily rebel
against the power they subverted it by being free
you know they just subverted it by saying things
you know that you should have gotten arrested for
but you didn't because they didn't say it in a
rebellious way but they were they were free and
I think that that's what artists have to be and I
I think you know when you were talking about the
fact that we're having a kind of conversation
that people don't have that's what it is we're
free you know and and in order to be free you
have to understand that somebody's going to want
to come and get you for it and do it anyway you're
going to lose some money you're going to lose some
friends you're going to lose some uh you might
be thrown off Twitter you know all those things
um you know that that is what freedom is freedom
is not being afraid of losing those things and
once you become afraid you're not free anymore
well maybe you are afraid but you do it anyway
well yes of course that's real courage yeah yeah
I mean yeah Andrew a couple of questions before we
wrap up uh given everything we've talked about Dr
Sebastian Gorka was sitting where you're sitting
we left it exactly as it is just for you um he's
he's very big on Trump and you've talked about
how it was a sad day that Trump had to come
along and you're not on the Trump train now
yeah that that's right I said from the very
beginning I think that the two I have to say that
I think the two people who got Trump exactly right
were me and Victor Davis handsome and I think I
said it first but Victor wrote a great book about
it so he so he wins but like but still it was that
he was a tragic figure from the start and he was
a tragic figure because the very things that made
him great also made him wrong and also we're going
to destroy him I mean that's what tragedy is the
things that that made him worth seeing and worth
supporting were ultimately going to destroy him
I think he lost that second election I I I said
he was going to I knew he was going to about two
years in because we had reached a point where
it took a loud mouth without many of the traits
that we think of as common decency to say the
simplest truth you know I mean that was the thing
that was beautiful about Donald Trump he would say
things that could easily be interpreted as racist
he was not a racist I don't think he I don't
think he was a racist at all but he would say
things that could easily be interpreted as right
because he didn't care if they called them races
but he also treated people badly he fired men who
deserve would you couldn't disagree with them you
can say they're doing a bad job but he firemen who
are deserving of respect in public or he you know
it was like he pulled the rug out from under them
he called people names he made up names which was
an adolescent thing to do it all worked you know
I I got it I under I understood it the minute I
saw the people react to it I didn't understand it
at first but the middle I saw the people react to
it I thought oh he's speaking for them he is
the voice of the people but at the same time
he was the voice of the people he was also this
narcissistic uh guy without very good manners
and I think that that's what killed him I think
it'll kill him again if he runs I think he's the
only the only Republican who could possibly lose
to Joe Biden he might not he might beat him but
I think he's the only one who could lose to him
so you a DeSantis guy yeah I I like the Santos he
hasn't been tested on the national scene you
know but I really like his fighting attitude
and as Gorka will tell you he wouldn't exist if
it weren't for Trump everything good Republican
party has come down from Trump he he recreated the
Republican Party the the guts they sometimes show
now which they never did before the uh the the
unwillingness to Simply drift to the left which
they've been doing for decades uh all of that was
a gift to Trump the the big idea which somebody
told me years ago was the idea that Republicans
need to understand is you're not running against
the Democrats you're running against the Press
but the press the media the news media in this
country is the enemy of the people just like
Trump said it was he was if there was one thing
he was a hundred percent right about it was the
news media watch I just the other day played a
montage of him taking the Press apart I was in I
couldn't stop laughing I mean it was just it was
delightful he he was the man of the moment he was
the man we needed um I have I have many many good
things to say about them people who say oh you're
never Trump or just lying I was the first guy at
the daily wire to come in and say I'm voting for
Trump and Shapiro yelled at me for like hours you
know like if you've ever heard the way Shapiro
talks about yeah that scene where the Godfather
where Sonny gets machine gunned [Music] um and
I voted for him twice and I vote for him again
if I have to but I think if if he had if he had an
ounce of Grace he would say I christened DeSantis
the new me and let him go if nothing else I'm so
tired of 80 year old men running our government
you know 70 and 80 year old men it is time for
this new generation to come along and the census
is good at what he does I mean he took that state
and he turned he took he took a purple State and
he turned it into a red state by sheer competence
you know by getting it right Trump didn't really
accomplish that much in terms of long term
because he wasn't you know people always say
well he's not a politician being a politician is
a profession you know so he couldn't get any laws
passed everything was executive orders was all
wiped Away by Joe Biden um so yeah I think his
time came I think he was the man of the moment
uh cometh the hour cometh the man he was a gift
I always say he was a godsend but so was King Soul
you know after a while you know your time runs out
uh he was a godsend he was he was the man of the
moment uh and I think that moment is passed and
if the Republicans can learn what he taught them
they will become a great party and the final thing
I want to ask you before we do our usual uh last
question is you know I've talked about how what
we need is a post-woke world because wokeness is
crazy we all know I think it's the every action
causes an equal and opposite reaction I see the
anti-work side which we're part of to some extent
going crazy to now staring into the abyss thing
and we need to move beyond that do you have a
vision for how we do that I do you won't like it
though go to church well you know I mean that our
churches your churches are empty our churches
are sort of uh collapsing uh but we should make
new ones we need to make new ones we need to
make churches we need to gather in our homes
together as they did it first and talk about what
it means for there to be a god um because here's
the here's the thing there actually is a god it
doesn't matter whether you believe in or not there
actually is one life even the things you believe
in only make sense if there's a God there you know
if there's any the only leap of faith I ever took
the only leap of faith I ever took was to say it's
it's better to give a beggar bread than it is to
torture a child to death you can't make that case
without God that case once you believe that you
believe in God once you believe that there is some
level above us that our actions refer to right
because what you're saying when you're saying
something is good is you're saying there is
some place where there is good and bad and our
uh our actions speak that it's it's not that I
have a little Ghost Inside Me that's going to
float up to heaven when I die it's that I am
I I speak an idea I am a word that speaks an
idea of me the idea of me and that idea exists
somewhere you know it exists in the mind of God
and so I don't think we have to go back to
the Middle Ages I don't think we can go back
to the Middle Ages and we shouldn't if we could
but I think we need to talk about what it means
if no this is not a Multiverse where we just
happen to live in the universe that looks very
much like it was created by a gigantic invisible
Jew you know that we there actually is something
spiritual something Supernatural something
above nature in the world and if we don't
um if we don't say that we have no argument this
this is what I it's hard to accept I understand I
understand why it's hard to accept but if we don't
make that argument then the left is right why
should you embrace your gender you know I heard I
was Mary Harrington I was reading Mary's book and
uh she was talking about a man a young man who
went into puberty and said I'm being poisoned
by these chemicals these chemicals are turning me
into something I don't want to be and I thought
well that's a rational statement if there's no
God you don't want to be this and these chemicals
are in fact turning you into something but if
that's something that you are refers to something
above yourself which I'm that's what I believe I
believe we are a language material is a language
then there's a reason to sort of say well what
am I going to do with this manhood that's been
given to me this you know what is this manhood
does is it a what if it's a gift what if it
has obligations what if I have an obligation uh
to open the door for my wife even though she's
perfectly capable of opening the door for herself
what if I have an obligation to throw myself in
front of her if there's danger you know what
does it mean to be a man what does it mean to
be a woman uh what are the sacrifices I'm willing
to make to be that person you cannot make that
argument um without some sense of the spiritual
and to be honest even though I'm a devout
Christian and I believe that that is the ex the
great expression of truth because it's so human
um you know I just think you have to start from
somewhere you know that they're that they're we're
not we're not just uh what's what's the word they
you know we're not Meat Puppets you know we're not
uh we're something else we are we speak a word
so that that is the beginning of the anti-woke
thing that you know C.S Lewis great Christian uh
apologist said you can't really he was talking
about a poem he was talking about Paradise Lost he
said you can't really judge a thing until you know
what it's for you know you can't really judge
a corkscrew until you know what it's supposed
to do and so you can't really judge people in
society until you have some you can State what
it's supposed to be and for too long the right
has been saying well we you're happier if you can
make money you know the answer then America gives
you the right to make money and then you can make
more money and if you and if you can even make
more money you think like eventually people turn
around and say you know that's not doing it for me
you know that does it for some people some people
want to be billionaires you know never occurred
to me if I want to be a billionaire I certainly
wouldn't have gone into the writing profession
you know there's something that we're here for
and I do think it involves love and relationship
and love of something Beyond ourselves that this
world only expresses and when you begin with
that you get very quickly to ideas like freedom
uh to ideas like relationship marriage uh respect
you know again we don't have to go back to the
Middle Ages to realize that those are things
that that matter to us and that you can build
a society on you can't build a society on like
oh you know you're a black guy so you committed
a crime but you're not a criminal because black
people were oppressed that's like you know then
you get what we have in Chicago now which is
being Torn to Pieces as we sit here talking
the poor people pouring into the streets tearing
into pieces um you cannot build a society like
that woke is right if there's no God woke is some
some bits of work makes sense if there's no God
um and it better be a god Bingo if
there's not we're in big trouble yeah
Andrew what a pleasure it's been
uh thank you so much for coming
on the show if people want to find your
books if they want to follow you online
if they want to watch you on the wire
how do they do that well you can start
by going to andrewclaven.com yes I always say
there's no ease in Cleveland it's k-l-a-v-a-n
um but Andrew cleveland.com will send you all
my other places and Andrew Clay at Andrew claven
as my Twitter feed and and the daily wire
I've got my podcast is now on every Friday
um and uh it's different no one else no one else
does what I do so it's something it's worth it's
worth tuning in absolutely fantastic it's great to
talk to you well thank you it's been an absolute
pleasure and of course we're not going to let you
go without some questions for uh paid supporters
or locals that only they'll get to see but before
that the last question we always ask and you may
have done this already but what is the one thing
we're not talking about as a society yeah that
was my last answer I mean I think this started
in in the 1500s this decline you know the long
withdrawing Roar of the tide of faith I think we
have now reached the bottom of that Niche said you
know this is a catastrophe that God is dead and
the moral Network on which Europe is based has
is gone uh and this and he said this is going to
be a catastrophe it certainly has been you know
um and so that that's the thing we're not
talking about because we're we've got this
idea that you can't make an argument from God
because not everybody accepts that premise
but when you make the argument that there's no
God that's a premise I don't accept so I think
that we should be Fearless in saying in asking
the question asking the questions of the left
you know I think that was what was so great about
Matt Walsh's documentary what is a woman he asked
the question yeah that's a spiritual question
you know that's not a physical question that's
a spirit you know because when you say what
is a woman it's not really the x's and the Y's
and the this and that that a woman is we know
what a woman is the minute we see it you know
and I think we have to ask those questions what
do you think you're here for what is what is your
purpose you know you tell me um because I'll build
that Society uh and I think once you do that you
get very quickly to something that looks kind of
like the Constitution uh you know power being kept
at Bay so the individual can thrive there we
go Andrew Cleveland it was absolute pleasure
talking to you thank you so much for coming on the
show join us on locals where we're going to ask
Andrew some of your bonus questions take care and
we'll see you soon take care and see you soon guys
envisage a politically neutral filmmaking industry
and what steps events would it
take to achieve that outcome
foreign [Music]